what is going on everybody and welcome
to i think
part four of the generative python
transformers videos
uh in this video what we're gonna be
doing is building a tokenizer
and so if you're a little unfamiliar
with tokenizers we use them with natural
language processing
to convert strings of text because this
is kind of unacceptable the machine
doesn't
really understand strings of text we're
trying to convert that into something
the machine does
understand like vectors of values
right that that makes more sense to the
machine that's quite a large one let's
uh let's shrink a couple of these
uh so so this is more along the lines of
what the machine expects as
input so tokenization is all about
converting this to
something more like this now how we do
that there's
so much uh so many different ways that
we can do that from
a classic kind of bag of words model
where just each word
gets a unique id arbitrarily all the way
to what we're going to be using today
which i
think is kind of the latest and greatest
which is bite level
bite paren coding which is basically
you're going to it's even like kind of
the industry standard was to take sub
words um
and kind of piece those together but
even even when you do that you would be
very surprised
how many possible combinations of
strings there are
and you you either need a huge uh a huge
vocabulary
you know which i don't know like a
million okay
uh or you have to deal with unk tokens
which are just if it's not contained
within the vocab
it gets an unk token or an unknown um
so unk tokens are very makes it hard for
the model the model is never
going to really learn what an unk token
is um
and then having a like i say a vocab
size of 1 million that's a very
large vector that's also very hard for
a model to learn so it seems to me that
byte-level bite-pairing coding
essentially allows you to have a very
very small
vocab size and yet have complete and
total coverage
and never have an unk token so that's
what we're going to be using
and for this tutorial or video
i'm not really calling this a tutorial i
am no expert on
um on any of this right i'm very new to
hugging face i'm very new to
transformers as well i'm this is me
learning so i'm gonna be referencing the
following things this is kind of the
hello world example from hugging face uh
there's quite a few things that have
changed and have been updated here i
don't know why
one of the things at least they
acknowledge i don't know why they don't
update this maybe
someone thinks for seo purposes that
it's better to keep it um
fire that person but
then there's also a collab that they
link to uh
and this has kind of one of the updates
we'll talk about it when we get there
but even that is outdated so we'll we'll
make another fix to that and then
finally i've got the
docs up for the gpt2 versions because
this hello world example
is actually using a bert model now i do
plan to
possibly check out using a burp model at
some point i think combining a burp
model and gpt2 model like having them
both at the same time
would make a pretty awesome autocomplete
so i kind of want to check them both out
but for now we're going to be doing uh
gpt 2. so i will be referencing that
stuff
so if you see me looking over that's
what i'm doing so
uh so yeah let's go ahead and begin so
the first thing that we're going to do
is
from tokenizers we're going to import
that byte level bpe
bp uh tokenizer
so from here what we want to do is
let me open up our directory yeah
so uh the the tokenizer takes in a
cluster of files or at least that's kind
of the default
if you just happen to have one large
file that's fine
but they can also take in a kind of a
big batch of files
so uh so yeah so we'll start with uh
reading this file in so
we'll just say paths and we'll say that
equals a list and then we'll just grab
the file name here and pass that in but
as time goes on you could have probably
chunks of files and paths
as far as i can tell this will not help
you memory wise
like this doesn't really matter if this
is either one giant file or a cluster of
little files
um the problems that we will hit later
on down the road
uh seem to be unimpacted by whether it's
one giant one or
a bunch of little ones let me put this
over here cool
so then what we're going to specify is a
tokenizer
and this part kind of confused me when i
first got started here
and you basically you're going to wind
up kind of defining a tokenizer twice
so first you have this like tokenizer
this like bait i'm gonna call it a base
tokenizer
okay uh you have this like base
tokenizer that you train first
and then you load it into um
the uh i don't know the model specific
tokenizer that you intend to use
via hucking face so again i think that's
all kind of hugging face api
type stuff but um it at least for me
that kind of confused me like why are we
defining a tokenizer
twice but anyway i just want to raise
your attention to that just in case
we get to it and i don't talk further
about why we're doing that
so tokenizer so this is a byte level bpe
tokenizer
now what we want to do is we want to
actually train that tokenizer let me see
if i can get a good
copy and paste possibly
from cool
so in fact let's just take i'm just
literally copying
and pasting from this right here i'm
going to copy that
and paste it here boop so pads pads
that's good 52k
that's i think the default for gpt2 min
frequency
my guess is it has to occur twice that
shouldn't actually be necessary i'll
leave it there because that's there
but uh this is the beginning of an
a sentence uh this is padding so if
you're
if you know you you you can't have a
variable input to the neural network
so if you so for example i think the
actual
length of gpt2 the context is 1024 so
1024
and we have limited we haven't even
tokenized yet because i didn't we didn't
we have no idea
how like before you tokenize
and before you build your data set you
have no idea of knowing
um how long will a sequence let's say a
sequence is 100 characters how long will
that sequence be after it gets tokenized
we
we don't know we can't know until we
have a tokenizer so
and i don't know that i want to truncate
stuff like ideally we would have samples
that aren't truncated
because there might be a really
important piece of information that got
truncated so i just i would rather
not do that so anyway i'm just
i'm just trying to find out and so right
now we're using 512
but eventually we'll probably increase
that but anyways that's what the padding
is for because you might have some
samples that are 400
tokens long and then some samples are
500 tokens long
they're all going to be passed in as a
1024 context so you're gonna have to pad
the rest of them like the rest of the
tokens um unk
hopefully we don't need the unk token
and then the mask token we purely need
that for later when we go to
generate sequences the generator is
going to
try to fill in the mass token which in
our case will just be at the end
of the uh the sequence more on that
later just know these are just kind of
some
starting special tokens so
then uh save uh
when did we train it oh did we oh it's
right here i was like wait we're saving
the model we're not even training it
um so that's funny
so what we'll do is we'll just save it
to a folder called tokenizer
and i don't know if it's going to make
it so we'll just go ahead and make it
real quick tokenizer
cool so uh let me
open up a terminal now
and let us python 3 tokenizer
dot pi and yeah let's go ahead and run
that see what happens
so it goes pretty quick uh this is a
small file so it's not
too too surprising and what we should
have
if we did we did save it i hope uh
tokenizer yes so now you have two files
in here you've got merges.txt and then
you've got vocab.json
so mergers.txt i think is more of your
byte level information
what we want that we can actually kind
of look at and read is here so these are
your tokens and then their respective id
now i think this will be ordered by um
uh occurrence that's the word i was
looking for
but i'm not 100 on that i could be wrong
um so
anyway here we have like for example
support constructed um
and then this is its id did we go all
the way to the end yeah we did let's go
let's pick something a little more
common
um apparently this you know group of of
letters for example
l-i-e-s this is not lies alone
this could be part of something that
says implies or something like that
right these are just
pieces of words um and i forget what the
the uh these like g characters someone
can comment below
it's sick it signifies maybe start of
sentence or
her um you know precedes a space or
follows a space rather
um i'm trying to think of what else
anyway i think it has something to do
with that but anyway someone
someone smarter than me can comment
below what those little funky
g characters are doing um anyway
um yeah so you can kind of look through
here and in fact one thing we
might even help is if we turned on uh
word wrap am i blind
am i it is under view there it is
boop okay so now we can see all of our
our characters so yeah my guess is maybe
it's not an order of occurrence because
i
really doubt this is a super common one
so anyway i don't know um
oh yeah maybe the g is like a space
one two three four five yeah
maybe that's what it is maybe it's a
space character
i don't know like i said someone feel
free to educate me
um if i'm seeing such weird ones like
this that
i think the g is it's like some sort of
space so it's like
you know an amount of indentation
essentially anyway
cool so we have a tokenizer now you
might be thinking oh we're done
but we are not um so interestingly
enough so coming back
uh to reference our tutorial here and
also
i think one thing we'll do is um
i'm going to make a constant here
train i don't know train base and we'll
set this now to be false
so we only need to train this one time
we don't need to do this every single
time
so if train base
uh we'll leave paths actually tokenizer
um
i think this will be good like that cool
so we don't need to waste time
uh training that every single time now
we can test this tokenizer
um so we can just make up some input
real quick so input will be
uh print
oh we can't use the double quotes let's
just use single quotes for now
hello world and then uh what is it
tokenizer input and then the input so
we'll say t equals tokenizer dot
tokenize uh if we run this again we need
to load it what was the
i forget what the syntax to load it is
but uh we'll get there in a second
tokenizer dot
uh not tokenized encode
input and then i think it's ids and
tokens yes
so we'll print t.ids
and we'll print t.tokens now the ids
will be the actual
um numbers i guess we'll call it
and then the tokens this will be the
corresponding
subword i guess i'll call it uh and
we are almost ready but what we actually
want to do is
uh
hmm i kind of want to load the uh
i don't know i'm not really sure what i
want to do because we could load we
could
i think the token i forget if it's like
load or load model
um but then we're right about to also
uh what i lost my uh
my hugging face docs here we go
save do they load it back i just forget
what the syntax is after you've saved it
yeah okay we're going to train it one
more time just so you can see
see these values and then we'll just
stop printing them out i suppose because
we're about to
make the gpt2 tokenizer and i don't feel
like adding a
bunch of logic and then not using it so
again so these are your ids
so these are just the numerical values
so print you know print hello world
became this vector right here and then
this
is just showing you the chunks so hello
world
uh interestingly enough we actually did
not get any sub
words they just it just learned to split
out
certain elements but interest also
interestingly for example
an opening parenthesis with a single
quote
that is its own unique token so if we
changed
to let's say we change this to
this we should see that
it actually tokenizes it differently
hello world and then we'll come over
here
we'll rerun that
right so the you know hello and world
wound up with the exact same uh you know
ids
but the thing that defers and same thing
with like the explain ex
exclamation point uh but the things that
defer
are these tokens here right uh opening
parentheses and then double quote that
gets a different
uh a different id
but i promise there will also be sub
words
i can't think of a really good one maybe
some of those like really long
exceptions
um that might be one you know like an
import is probably going to be
its own token um anyway
so we now have um we've got this like
trained
tokenizer that is saved and i'm actually
just go well we'll leave
input but i'm going to delete this other
stuff
so once we have this like base tokenizer
the next thing that we need
is the tokenizer that actually
corresponds to
the model that we're going to use it use
it with
so i guess we'll come up to the tippity
top
and what we'll do here is from
transformers
we're going to import gpt2
config gpt 2 it'll be a miracle if i
don't typo any of this
lm for language model uh head
model and gpt 2
tokenizer so again this is kind of the
part that confused me and
i could be wrong but i don't think you
can just load gpt to tokenizer like this
uh and do like like i don't think you
can actually do
what just happened i don't think you can
actually do that
um i don't think it works that way
in effect uh so
if we go python 3
uh tokenizer
missing to do we not true
right yeah so so when you attempt to
like initialize this
this parameter it's not going to work
because um
or initialize this object uh it's not
going to work
because it expects to have that vocab
file already
so yeah i thought so so coming back
over here so what we do is we first
train this like byte level bpe encoder
and then once we have that we can load
the results of that
in via that gpt2
tokenizer so to do that what we will do
is once again specify
tokenizer equals and this will be gpt to
tokenizer
dot uh from underscore
pre-trained and it will be
tokenizer tokenizer
from pre-trained i almost wonder is
there a
i just i don't think so in it missing
two
like it like you would have to no matter
what
you could not just you can't even
initialize it
without a vocab file in a merges file
but then
to you have to say dot from pre-trained
i wonder if it would work if you didn't
even say from pre-trained i don't know
anyway
whatever this is what the tutorials say
to do so we're going to do it this way
anyway so this just tells it the
directory uh
from where to load the uh
the tokenizer now i also found
that these like so like let's pull back
up
oh vocab
that's bad unk mask so we already have
these but uh you still have to let
the model know so once we've loaded in
that tokenizer i'm going to copy this
real quick we're not typing that out
and paste so we still need to add
special tokens and just like
notify the gp2 gpt2 tokenizer
uh say that really quickly uh we have to
still tell it this is the end of
sentence token this is the beginning of
sentence this is the
unk pad mask so we still have to inform
it hey these are the these are the ones
that we're going to use
and essentially what this means is um
you could actually make these anything
you want you don't have to use these
ones now i will say
i i did i tried to make like my own new
line token
and i couldn't figure it out i couldn't
figure out how to get it to just like
recognize like i want this new line
token i want that to be a token
i could not get it to work so um
there's that i did try to add one but it
seems like they just have their own
special
list of you know these special tokens
and you can only
like pick those you can't like make
more so anyway um if somebody knows how
to add
like truly add a token like a new line
character
a token let me know so
after we've done that we can redo
the the tokenization now so we can say
t equals tokenizer and again it'll be
dot
encode uh the input
and then in this case uh we'll print t
and this one's a little different so in
this case when we print t
we don't have to say t.ids it will just
dot encode
actually encodes it so to hopefully we
did this right oh we're probably going
to retrain let me change that to false
while i'm thinking about it
so we don't need to do anything like
that again but anyway when it was done
uh you can see here it did uh it encoded
them
and the ids are the same as what we had
before
okay so now we have our uh gpt2
tokenizer and i think um i think that's
basically everything i really want to
show i guess the only other thing is now
that we have the gpt2 tokenizer
take note that so when we pass we are
going to encode
stuff that that goes into the model and
then the model is going to spit out
its decode so the d code
is also going to be something like this
it'll be a vector of values
or maybe it'll be like one more new
value that gets appended or
you know who knows it kind of depends on
what your task is
but um the only other task that you're
gonna do with your tokenizer is you
might also decode
so we could also print um
tokenizer.decode
t and this should just bring us back to
where we
uh started
right so the so one thing to take note
of is it did not
do something like this where it was like
this
vector or list of sub strings that's not
what it did when it decoded
it actually just rebuilt back together
the sentence so once you pass things
through the model
you just decode them and then you could
have you know
this beautifully formatted code so to
speak
we'll still have to fix the new line
character thing but other than that
that's all we'll
we'll really have to do so uh from there
i think i will save uh the next step for
the next tutorial and that will be
actually training the model so the next
thing that we have to do once we have
the tokenizer
that's our kind of final uh dare i call
it a pre-processing step i think it's
fair to say
that's the final pre-processing step
before we actually start
feeding data into our model so
essentially what we're going to want to
do
is load in uh this very small
this very small file uh into our model
in an attempt
to train something from it again uh i
won't actually train
i'll i'll see if this model generates
anything for us this this code
mostly because i'd like to at least host
a file big enough that you could train
something from it
but then i will actually be training a
model on the
the dgx station a ver a full-size model
on all of the code that i have which is
about 100 gigs of
python code and i suspect that model
could turn out to be
uh a pretty good model so i'm excited to
see that i don't think on this data set
uh i i don't think it'll be a very good
data set a very good model rather
uh from this data set but who knows uh
we'll see
so uh yeah if you guys have any
questions comments concerns
uh whatever you know the deal feel free
to leave them below this video
is sponsored by a neural network from
scratch i don't know if anybody's ever
heard of neural networks from scratch
but you can learn more about it
from nnfs.io if you want to learn how to
build neural networks
uh from scratch in python purely just to
learn more about how they work
the end end goal is not actually to
build your own framework
but that is basically what we do but the
idea is to
uh learn more about how to use the
popular libraries
uh like keras like pytorch and actually
understand
you know what's going on there uh just
to give you a better understanding and
the way that we're doing that
is by building neural networks truly
from scratch and python so
anyway if that's something that sounds
interesting to you you can go to nnfs.io
and check it out
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you